the propaganda that they were actually
sending out to young Muslims like us in
the beginning was more like a more like
a romantic jihad Danny you're going to
Syria to protect the civilians and to
say wasn't about beheading at the
beginning I wasn't about beheading or
killing your it was there to defend the
Syrians that I honestly I came in for
that first but Isis changed changed very
dramatically in 2015 I mean not four or
five months into Isis I wanted to leave
I was on holidays okay yeah my parents
isn't that my family didn't you just
might like my intention my intention was
actually Turkey I had no intention of
going at that time but I was sympathetic
to Isis for the cause and at that time I
don't know one day I was in Turkey and I
thought I'm serious okay attack again
and see what's not far from here go and
contact a Isis fighter he gave me a
number I'm sure you know to give you a
number smuggler smoke that takes you to
the texture for the texture 14 Syria any
decor family no no I wanted to tell them
but I knew they would be against it you
know it's a no yeah I was caught on the
border if you know I was caught by the
Turkish army and then I was transferred
to the Turkish intelligence where I
found other Isis fighters found 50
roughly from a variety of countries I
told them I told the authorities at
first I want to live and I told the Isis
fighters I want to live and I know it
made you want to believe another when
you're with Isis fighters combines in
the room and all they talk about is she
heard and this this this is almost like
peer pressure so you feel you're out of
line if you disagree with them so I went
with the flow most or everything every
one of the
want to go to so I house has hesitant at
first and then after we after month
Dutch intelligence agency here comes
officials two of them understand you
guys are going to see there's a exchange
and we were exchanged with 40 or hostage
hostages
you weren't given the choice I was
giving choice but I made the wrong
choice I guess tell me the choice the
choice was a either go back to your
country you'd be deported back to
country or you can go with this exchange
follow through with the exchange so I
follow through with the exchange but you
decided to go back into Syria and with
Isis at that point yeah my attentional
thinking at that stage to Syria but to
see what see how the situation is Syria
and help the Syrian people I didn't my
intention wasn't really defy its
beginning when I arrived in Syria they
have a regime they interview you and see
who you are and make sure you not to spy
and then they send off and I did not
speak Arabic so I did not know what was
going on they transferred to me hammer
region of man and I was on guard you
today I did a train their weapons
training and then I went from there to i
sister to enhance a pocket in the desert
the guard duty against a simulation and
they sent us off to
hosaka if I against PKK tell hem is near
the Turkish border near the Iraqi border
and there that's why I saw the saw the
reality of Isis what did you see cannon
for that they just send you to die that
no you're going
three groups three level three and
squads comprised of maybe 15 soldiers
all four most of them were killed air
strikes from the from the battle there I
didn't participate about that I was like
I said haven't spoken English so huh I
was like reinforcement that's basically
reinforced was what I told the bat in
front of me they just send one squad
dead guy and they attend the same squad
same way didn't care about fighters
didn't care about Islam didn't care
about it was just for the purpose of
Doria you are essentially selling
yourselves not to assume you're selling
yourselves to Isis I'm just interested
in your distinction that you didn't
fight no you're right on the from
gadgety gadgety and then there was a
battle but I was that we were comprised
of three squads I was the last one at
the back I think we would still think
that was part of the fight
what's your distinction distinction I
didn't fire a bullet just that one might
clash the cough weirdest night if the
fighting him got closer to you I've had
to defend myself a very Snowberry
hitting it was it was it was a village
in front of us and it was two lines
essentially we would basically on from
the last front line on the final front
line and two other squads they would go
to nap no-man's land and to
no-man's-land and they would enter this
village which was under there at peak
okay okay so tell me what you saw that
there shocked you so much tell me give
me an example
describe what what what stuck in your
mind is being horrified you
you saw people dying yeah so people
dying in front of me then I would see
their pictures later but PKK with posted
pictures up on Thunder near after and
injured brothers that the injured
fighters that would come back and the
airstrikes as well I went to the
security services the office I said I
want to quit Isis there's no problem
Congress took me into car and they took
me to I'm sure you've seen it's
well-known the Stadium in Raqqa mm-hmm
that's that was the prison for Isis for
the security services accused of spying
or FSA fighters as well Isis fighters
majority of them Isis fighters
ironically majority from foreign
fighters so I was in there for month and
frightened I mean they blindfolded in
the beginning and it CB thinks Apprendi
and stuff so that's frightened didn't
beat me
well the harsh woody very harsh so after
month I I gave him I couldn't I gave him
and I I spoke to him and I said to him
okay I don't want to quit daughter I
don't want to leave I don't want to
fight so give me a civilian job so they
transferred me to Military Police which
essentially do checkpoints and you don't
fight you as mainly just in the office
and either as a laptop or just gaming
base had a gaming laptop just left in
there doing my own thing you can imagine
how difficult it is for people to accept
that you had absolutely nothing to do
with the atrocities and what was going
on inside an Isis control there's very
many fighters many fighters have nothing
to do what atrocity is the atrocities
would tell me the bad things the
headings didn't you I've never killed
anyone okay
the people the groups that kill
civilians or Isis fighters that it's
it's they have parts of the security
services but why should we believe you
it's what ask any artist fighter I'm
asking you have you killed anyone no I
haven't killed anyone and why should we
believe you
it's up to you to believe me or not look
tell me why should we believe you
what waters what reason can give us
first you've been in Isis territory for
three years I know you were trained you
were on the front line yeah and you
managed to coexist with them exactly
away I was in prison for one month and I
was present twice ok second time how
long a month ago okay but you lived
there for three years
yeah yeah we often spend I was in and
out of work
I went AWOL for maybe a year more year
maybe less than a year but in and out
after I was working the hospital I
decided to leave and six months maybe I
was able that's basically hide in your
house and then from April April March
2017 I left Emma and I went to Raqqa
Abel I stayed in my house at the
PlayStation for playing GTA or metal
gates all in my house and I was it my
friend he also wants to even watch
movies normal life beyond you wouldn't
do anything that night we wouldn't go
out coz this checkpoint and then the PKK
started attacking Raqqa and then I we
decided to leave to the resort there are
certain same thing sat down in the house
PlayStation movies nothing nothing no
connection with Isis I mean I was Isis
by name and I'd go out with military
uniforms that Isis wouldn't you know
they won't question you into the cool I
the ice is called Co of Isis is not the
fighters the fighters a cannon for the
ages they don't understand anything it's
descriptive services the
the hiss per se religious police the
military police and they are the main
they what one Isis in the cities but you
were in the military please hmm so how I
was transferred that when I was I wanted
leave and he was a good cover for me no
one would no one would think I wanted
out of the military police you were also
part of the structure that was enforcing
biases rules and regulations yeah
checkpoints and military police is just
for Isis fighters this day has nothing
to do with is there do you think do you
think I mean do you take any
responsibility for what your involvement
with them I take responsibility I was
with Isis I was with the terrorist
organization I mean well I mean I didn't
kill anyone I hope I didn't oppress
anyone I mean I mean I did have a crush
the coffin military uniform but I didn't
I didn't hit anyone I didn't oppress
anyone if you understand I mean I was
there in with military police family so
please like I said I was in the office
even I mean if I would bring you some of
the military if they still alive the
military police some of them they would
say which one is the most laziest or
which one doesn't do any work order it
would be me they'd say how long how long
he's well known for like just he just
sits down and slap time she's playing
his games yeah honestly I understand you
hard to believe it tell me what you want
to happen now I don't know many Isis
fighters are not what would you proceed
them to be many of them who came simple
cause fight fight the Assad regime but
they happen to join the group Isis there
were many options I was actually
planning to join a different group I had
shown in Italy I had shown not terrorist
organizations a well-known reproduction
day but the reason I joined Isis is
because they announced the caliphate a
cosplay is kind of like a little magnet
think it attracts all the foreign
fighters to Isis because Caliphate it's
a big big claim if you claimed a
Catholic and that's what caused many of
the phone fighters to join Isis and a
harsher and more the FSA faction so that
because they played with the religion
they when it's concerned with the
religion you can't question the religion
you know you wouldn't want to question
and so when they would give their
evidences for Islam
maleic you're betraying your own
religion if you don't it was very hard
for even when I was wanted in the
beginning when I wanted to leave Isis I
was scared that I would become there as
they would say it hypocrite to Islam
they I mean that I'm almost I'm so I
wouldn't become hypocrite yet - it was
very hard to convince yourself day to
get yourself out of the the ideology of
Isis very it's very powerful very
powerful ideology tell me what your
feeling is about the whole going back
home I'd love to get aspirators know
it's a great country
there's nothing love to go back continue
my studies in university I was gonna
study a big regret and that fake regret
I didn't get any I missed an University
that was I was working all most of my
teenage years to go to uni and then I
got a place in uni and then I just came
here it was a spontaneous kind of like
just like that click and cut Syria very
big mistake
going to Syria wasn't a mistake joining
Isis was the mistake I wouldn't if I
wasn't sure would do another faction or
didn't you Mountaineer I'm fine with
that
I'm happy and you know go back and forth
to Turkey and go back to Britain and see
it Syria it's a second home to me the
people are amazing it's just a shame
Isis betrayed the certain people I mean
can you ever imagine having a normal
life again
yeah I hope so I hope I can have a
normal life again back in the UK well
depending on depending on the the courts
and the how I'd be prosecuted that's the
worry I have on whether I have a long
prison sentence or we wish or it's a
sentence below I don't know honestly I
don't know do you think that surprised
that you have to pay though surprised of
course I have to I guess I have to I
mean everyone ever coming on has to pay
the price
do you feel do you feel a terrorist
uh-huh even though you know him very
well
honestly no I mean terrorists it's when
you think of terrorists to think someone
you know with their masks and you know
with a sword - you know / hitting people
and terrorizing people well honestly I
was no I mean I was just relaxed hiding
in Raqqa with several Syrian civilians
Italy befriends it from Italy playing
PlayStation or to go around and bike
rides and normal life no life is in Isis
territory and trying to a varied Isis
checkpoints and some of them were Isis
Runaways as well from the same province
of Maine so extraordinary can you
imagine anyone believing I know I want
to write the book one day hopefully I
want to write a book on how ice happened
how Isis is the news
story sounds unbelievable it sounds I
stayed in Raqqa was we're searing seeing
videos posted by Isis of people being
crucified and beheaded and flogged and
homosexuals thrown off the edge of it
and you were playing PlayStation yeah
the Playstations in there as well in my
house and Arizona it's probably captured
by the same regime now because they took
that thing
I have a picture actually I pictures on
my phone of what the PlayStation if I'm
in still stay in Syria I hope I I can
can try and redeem myself by working for
the Syrian Revolution again how I did in
the beginning whether if it's
surveilling whether it's with the FSA or
whatever well I hope I can redeem myself
that way either in Syria or prison in
Britain
I guess face justice I mean I have no
problem facing justice I mean for me if
I get prosecuted I get prosecutor I mean
I guess it's it's my destiny if I get
Messiah I don't regret it I mean I don't
spend more of my rest more waste more of
my life in prison or you know I want to
get on with my life I want to get back
to life I mean 22 I wasted every
everyday I think I'm wasting another day
in Isis territory wasting another year
and waste of wasted this night when I
was in Isis I would waste it now in
present weight always thing again in
prison I you know prison is of course no
no it's a good prison well if I guess is
depending on my prison sentence that's
the problem
I mean if it's very longer I don't want
to go back to Britain because sure I do
the prison and go on and live my life
get a job or continue my studies and
politics or whatever you just open the
net and we Twitter and you see do you
see you
you know the new developments in
technology or the new Playstation or
Missy you've missed you misty
mr. wall filled life missed the you
missed home yourself what do you miss
about him apart from Playstation no
listen I miss just having a normal life
forgot the Playstations this is nothing
just missing uh my family I'm missing
I'm going missing studying honestly I
miss studying I miss study and we
studying miss reading books miss like
every miss hanging out going to London
shopping I'm shopping what do you miss
about your family
I miss my miss my younger brother my
only brother I have my younger brother I
miss him a lot
what have you said to your parents about
now he'll know about your whole decision
how you ended up here have you had Frank
discussions about the beginning of I
mean do you feel any guilt about what
you've put them through yeah I feel like
cause of stress of course and pain and
they always worried if I don't message
them after a week of scares if I've been
killed or you know mine a strike or
whatever I regret my name my family
greatness many that I put my family
through I put definitely put my family
through a lot I wish I could redeem
myself for that